abone ol
e herkese merhaba
Hayat seçiminiz olmayan evlere doğmakla
başlar Kimimiz bir sarayda kimdir
apartman dairesinde Kimimiz de kulübede
ya da belki çöp tenekesinden
buzlukta
bilmediğimizi bilmediğimiz in farkında
olmayıp daha sonra
bilmediklerimizi bilerek öğrenme aşkıyla
yola devam ederiz biz o öğrenmek
istedikçe Kafamızda binlerce sorular
verir Ben kimim Ben de istiyor Ben
büyüyünce Ben ne olacağım gibi onlarca
sorun Evet ilk adım ve ilk Kural Sen
kimsin
bu kimliklerimiz var Şu an sizin öğrenci
kimliğiniz evlat kimliğiniz spor
yapıyorsanız sporcu kimliğiniz gibi ve
Bizler bu kimliklerin görev tanımlarını
bilmediğimiz sıra cı doğru karar
veremeyiz
O bir çocuk eve gittiğinde Anneciğim ne
olur bana su verdiği çağırırken ben
okula döndüğümde den öğrenci kimliğinde
öğretmeninden aynı talepte
bulunacak bunları hiç gibi sel olarak
öğrenmek yerine size tavsiyem evinize
gittiğinizde
kimliklerinizi yazın ve kimliklerimizin
altına da görev tanımlarını yazın Bu
sizin ileride yapacağız planlarda
Kariyer planlama mızda hayatınızı
kolaylaştıracak Çünkü hayat bazen
istemediğimiz kimlikleri yaşatmak
durumunda da bırakın bize
Örneğin sekiz yaşında babasını kaybetmiş
bu maddi imkanları kısıtlı olan sokakta
gördüğümüz mendil satmaya ayakkabı
olmaya çalışan çocuğun kaderiyle sizin
kaderiniz bu sene değil Çünkü o çocuk
Sadece öğrenci
evlat kardeşi varsa abi ya da abla
kimliğinde Yaşamak bir yana artık evine
geçirmek durumundadır ve daha sekiz
yaşındayken
maalesef Baba kimliğinin
sorumluluklarımızın almıştır işte hal
böyle olduğu zaman o çocuk hayallerini
ertelemek Doktor olmak istiyorsa onun
yerine kardeşi okutmak annesini rahat
ettirmek çalışmak ve para getirmek
derken hayallerini sürekli erteler ve
Düşün bakalım ne kadar şanslısınız biz
Hayat size
1-0 galip mi 1-0 mağlup bu başlamış
kendinize doğru soruları sormamız
gerekiyor
bu doğru sorulara yanlış cevaplar
verdiğimizde maalesef yolumuzu
kaybederiz Biz Demek ki kendimizi
tanımının yanı sıra ikinci önemli şey
doğru soruyu kendinize sorma
doğrusu derken doğru sorular bize
hayallerimize götürecek ne olmak
istediğimiz değer yargılarımız
mutluluğun tercih ediyoruz huzursuz bir
tekniği agresif miyiz biz bu hayatın
içerisinde hangi duygularla var olmak
istiyoruz
en güçlü yanlarımız neler zayıflanırmı
neler örneğimiz
1.50 boyunda bir arkadaşımızı düşünelim
ve hayali dünya standartlarını bir top
model olmak mümkün mü bekliyorum ya da
şeker hastası olan bir insan düşünürüm
diyor ki ben bir haftada 5 kilo
vereceğim sağlık koşulları bunu elleri
yolu mümkün değil
bu hayalleri arttırabiliriz ya da
uçmak en büyük hayali ama yükseklik
fobisi var Evet bu hayalleri belki proje
kurumlarımızda imkânlarımız da ötürü
ertelemek zorunda kalabiliriz
gerçekleştiren ekle ertelemek arasında
fark vardır yani eğer sen korkularından
başka dersen yarın fiyat olabilirsin
Eğer şeker hastalığını tedavi etmek için
önem alırsa ilk ya 15 kilo değil iki
kilo verir Ama istediğin kiloya
ulaşabilirsin ama bir evli boyunu iki
metre bir 90 santim yapabilme şansım
olmadığına göre o zaman hayallerinin
ayaklarını yorganına göre uzatırsın
manken olmaz ama foto model olursun evet
özgürlüklerimiz
işi istediğimiz noktalarda kullanabilmek
yaşamsal şartlarımıza bağlı Sunay
Akın'ın çok sevdiğim bir cümlesi vardı
bu özgürlüğü elinden alınmış
çocuğa büyük diye
yazar geçiyor ve
şarkılar onu yapamazsın ne yaparsam
böyle olur yapamazsın gibi kısıtlamalar
yetişkinleri yani bizlerin kendi
korkularımızı çocuklarımızın üzerinde
empoze etme gibi pompalama lar sonucunda
hayallerinizden zaman zaman uzaklaşırız
bu noktada Düşünmeniz gereken şey şu
benim hayata dair hani doğru mu zerre
başlıyor ya avantajların ne zaman
taşlarım hayatını kolaylaştıran kişi ve
kurumlar benim hayatınızda atmamaya da
yavaşlama sebep olan katalizörler İşte
bunlar da yine Kağıt kalemi alıp
yazmanız gereken şeyler Çünkü Söz uçar
yazı kalır
bu hayat farklı sınavlarda bir asılıyor
Örneğin ben ben maalesef eğitim
sisteminin
dayatmaları
ailelerin yeterli kadar bilinçli olması
birçok parametre sayabiliriz
yanlış bir meslek seçmek durumunda
kaldım Çünkü benim dönemde kim sabaha
eğitim sisteminde şunu sormuyor dut sen
ne olmak istiyorsun Ben baba mesleğini
tercih ediyordum Doktor olmak istiyordum
ama beyaz ölümünden yakaladım doktor
bulamadım çünkü psikiyatri psikolog
olmayı çok istiyordum ne oldu
bu yanlış dua etme derdi Annem hep
Eskişehir'e gitmek istiyorum orada
arkadaşlarım var derdi Eskişehir'e
gittim ama Tıp Fakültesi'ni kazanarak
değil kim ya ben seni kızardı altı sene
boyunca
istemediğim bir mesleğin eğitimini aldım
ve şuan karşımıza bir kariyer yöneticisi
olarak Türkiye'nin ilk menajerlik
şirketini kurmuş bir menajer bir kas
rektör olarak konuşuyorum şu Hayat Neyse
ki bana bana yoldan döndürüp İkinci bir
şans daha ver e bitti baba mesleğim
değil abla Mesleğimi tercih etmiş oldum
İkincisi o kadar çok çalışıyordum ki hiç
Anne olmak gibi Duygu aklımda yoktu
Sanki
hayatında bir çocuk vesaire böyle bir
hedef yoktu 36 yaşında hayatının
erkeğini bulduğum zaman Çünkü ben Anne
Olmak İstiyorum ve doktorların ki
olamazsın
bu yeterli seviyede yumurta yok
inanamadım dedim ki yani Ben evleneceğim
nedenle olacağım Hayat beni sınıyor
Ne yapmam gereken şey vazgeçmek değil
bu nedenleri sorgulama değil Nasıl
bulmak Çünkü neden dediğimizde neden bir
başıma geldi Neden olmuyor dediğinizde
size hep olumsuz daha götürecek neden
nasıl aynı olur mu sorguladığımda
alternatiflerinden biri tüp bebek sahibi
olmaktı iki kez tüp bebek sahibi olma
çalışmadan sonra kıyafet hayatımız
prenses Dora
doğduk 8 sene boyunca anne çocuk
programı yaptık kendisinde de burada
kardeş olsun istiyordu Ben de ikinci kez
anne olmak istiyordum ama yaş gelmişti
44 Olmaz olmaz kesinlikle olmaz diyordu
Doktorlar yine almam gereken vitaminler
sağlığıma dikkat etmem kötü alışkanlığım
varsa Bırakmak gibi benim hedefe
taşıyacak eylemleri yaptıktan sonra 45
yaşında bu sefer de prensesim kızım
karar ver ana dünyaya geldim
Dolayısıyla inançlarımız dava o dönemde
çok kıymetli Ama eğer sizin gerek
fiziksel olarak gerek Maddi manevi
tetikleyici leriniz size engelli
işlerimiz var ise o zaman ya vazgeçmeye
Bileceksiniz ya da doğru zaman
bekleyeceksiniz
engelin yoksa vazgeçmek Sen kendi
engelli yaratma Yeter ki evet Hayal
kurmak bu üçüncü adım çok ciddi diş
çocuklara sorduğunuzda hayalleri
karşısına inanılmaz şaşırıyorsunuz bir
topik ayarlıyorlar biz ne yapıyoruz o
hayallerden çocuklarda yavaş yavaş
bunları çalıyor ve Sunay Akın'ın dediği
gibi onları bazen istemedikleri şekilde
büyütüyoruz
o Örneğin Dora benim hayalim olan Yüzme
sporunu yapması konusunda baskı
altındaydı hocalar da diyor ki doğru çok
güzelmiş o kesinlikle Yüzmeden almayın
falan adam hızlı gidiyor ve birinci
falan oraya cumartesi günleri yataktan
zorla kaldırıyordu ve üzmeye
götürüyordum bir gün verdim almaya
gittik hepiniz bolluk ve elektrik onun
etkiledin diye sorduğumda
yüzmeye bırakmayı dedi
Ben dedim ki Aman Tanrım sen çocuğunuz
değil kendi istediğin hayatı onu
Yaşatmaya çalışıyorsun ve o hafta
itibariyle onu Yüzmeden aldım Şimdi
durmadan resim yazıyor bu
tercihlerimiz yaşam koşullarınızı
belirliyor davranışlarımızı belirliyor
Dolayısıyla senin kendine soracağım Ben
kimim Ben de yapmak istiyorum düğünce ne
olmak istiyorum Bu sorular hayatım
boyunca mutluluğuna ya da mutsuzluğuna
atacağım imzadır bu asla unutma Eğer ki
yapmana engel yoksa Sakın abi vazgeçme
ben
kendi kariyerimi doğru plan yapmadığım
için
hatalarımdan ders alarak Oyuncu olmak
isteyen parmak kaldırsın diye bir kitap
yazdım hiç kimsenin tecrübesi sizin
tecrübeniz değildir ama sizin
hücrelerinde giden yolculukta
bu anahtarları mıdır
Dolayısıyla O kitapta da genç
arkadaşlara
olabildiğince ne yapılıp yapılmaması
gerektiğini izah etmeye çalışmama
gençler biliyorsunuz ki hiçbir zaman
tavsiyelerden hoşlandım ama yetişkin bir
de tavsiye bulmakta hiçbir zaman balık
geçmez Samuel beckett'in çok güzel bir
cümlesi var Ben edin mi Yenildin yine
yeni gelin daha iyi yenir vazgeçmeyin
Pes etmeyin
hayallerinizle gerçeğiniz arasındaki
mesafe ne kadar yakınsa o kadar mutlu
huzurlu olursunuz lütfen
hayallerimizin ayakları yere Sağlam
basın
Ve işinize işinizde mutlu huzurlu ve
sağlıklı olduğunu biliyorum görüşmek
üzere